hey what's the most
random [ __ ] that that if someone were to
check your playlist that you're
listening to
that would that would be like surprise
like oh this [ __ ] is listening
to this
uh you will probably find diedrich
hadn't sung god is good that's my [ __ ] i
play like it's a trap song
i don't know what that is god is good
god is
good oh that's so there's no nickelback
on your playlist
look at this photograph it's the only
one that makes me laugh that's how
i [ __ ] with them boys yo have you ever
been in a white strip club and they
played nickelback
hell yeah it's funny no honestly [ __ ]
back give these girls and they back they
all trying to be so dumb on the post
they go to that white strip club and
they throw on that niggle back or that
creed and you see a [ __ ] just just
they she dancing she throwing hair she's
just like it's like what is happening
give me the [ __ ] out of here throw your
nick around you ain't even getting naked
no more you just kept it whiplash
yeah you can't dance to that you can't
dance with that [ __ ] but you could fall
into it i thought the [ __ ] don't care
i watched mtv 6 in the morning when i
was going to school mr choice
you catch you catching balls blink 182
tight [ __ ] smash mouth you catch em she
says smash mouth you catch em you catch
em